bootstrap your business if you want to
have success as an entrepreneur you have
to learn how to bootstrap your business
from the ground up otherwise you're
going to spend all your money end up
broke and going back looking for a job
hi I'm Evan Carmichael I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and
today maintain a question from youtube
viewer Michelle Thank You YouTube guys
wrote in saying I have a plan to start a
hair coloring business on a lower budget
how do I find the company that
manufactures a product or do I have to
spend a lot of money on R&D chemist
Michelle you got to find a way to
bootstrap this thing do not go out and
start spending money until you found the
way to make money I hate spending money
until I'm making money anybody can spend
money right if I gave you a million
dollars i'm sure you define a million
ways of what and spend it but not many
people can make money invest your time
invest your energy invest all your ideas
and your thoughts into making this thing
happen but don't put in a ton of money
because if it doesn't work out you're
going to end up bankrupt and i don't
want that for you and it happens to too
many entrepreneurs you do not need to go
out and hire an expensive rd chemist to
make this thing for you experiment on
your own start small make it in your
kitchen try different things and see
what works you have to have a solid plan
in place before you go out and start
spending money this is for every
entrepreneur if you're starting the
business have a plan in place that you
know works before you go out and start
spending money Omeros in venture capital
business we saw so many entrepreneurs
who just wanted to spend money they had
not proven anything and that's the
hardest kind of money to raise if you
want to bring capital on into your
business you have to show that it works
not on a big scale but show that it
works and you should be just as ruthless
on your own business prove to yourself
that this works before you're going to
invest your money into it you're an
investor show that it works go out and
get some customers it doesn't mean you
have to go out and find tons of
customers if you can show that it works
on a small scale then it's worth
investing some dollars into it to grow
you have to learn bootstrapping it's so
essential as an entrepreneur because
this is on you and I don't want you
spending your life savings putting it
all into this business and not having it
work out your boots job but you start
small you find a way to make it work on
your own out of your house if it's in
your extra hours that's fine you keep
your full-time job as a way to you know
maintain your family that's fine but you
have to learn how to bootstrap your
business to get it to the point where it
can feed you pay your bills put food on
the table and then when you're putting
the money into it you know you're going
to yield it results because you've seen
it work start with your time start with
your energy show that you can get some
results and then put your money in to
blow it up to expand it to go for new
heights good luck for those of you
watching you like the video please give
it a thumbs up below I love seeing us
come in and I also want to hear what you
have to think about Michelle's company
or your own business feel free to leave
in a comment section below I always read
those I love seemed to come in thank you
guys I'll see you soon